first thing serious question right off
the top
when I'm watching Citadel which drink
should I have in my hand the mixed
cocktail that represents Citadel well I
don't know if they're one that
represents cereal but I'm a big fan of
the martini
[Music]
get a good dry martini yeah I like it I
like it and I love you as this character
as Bernard because he has a bit of
sarcasm he's a bit of a nerd he's The
Mastermind behind the project he's he's
Sleek he's a bit of everything I think
he's the would you say he's the heart of
Citadel I mean it must have been so
great to bring this character to life on
screen and these people are saying he is
the hardest yeah yes maybe it's true
he's trying to keep everything together
and every one together and two and and
yeah at the same time to achieve this
this this
ultimate end yeah which is you know to
bring Citadel back to life and Destroy
magical and you're and he's also one
step ahead of everybody and he's very
calm would you say you're like Kim like
very calm in that heart no you panic he
does Panic at certain times you'll see
but oh okay but normally he's he's
pretty on top of it yeah and the great
thing about the storyline is the fact
that you're you're dealing with losing
your memories from the past right if
there's something you want to remember
from the last two days let's say what's
that memory you want to remember forever
the memory I want to remember
or maybe not the last video two last two
decades a good meal
a good meal a taste of certain aspect of
a meal
and but it's the stuff that my little
kids oh I love that you're such a good
cook I think you cooked with Meryl
Streep for Julie and Julia right yeah we
did you did did you do this this time
with Priyanka oh why not I didn't meet
Priyanka until I was shooting much later
and I worked with her for one hour and
then I got to know her here during the
junket that's crazy I think I met her
for a second that was a yeah I know but
that's the way it is if you were to cook
with her what would you like to make
whatever she wants whatever she wants
yeah you could just make whatever I mean
let's talk about that a little bit
because uh again you had taught me that
pasta is okay for breakfast uh so I'm
gonna start doing that now and you are a
sex symbol on on social media and how do
you take that in and do you read the
comments and do any of them make you
blush yes
during lockdown when it first when it
all first happened yeah you know we had
all my kids at home all the older kids
were right they you know couldn't go to
university they couldn't you know
and that was when it all started
happening so we would read the comments
out loud and crying with laughter some
of them were so funny
yeah you were like oh my God who thinks
of that you know like what what did you
do you know
check it easy do you show it to your
wife and call us
be my age and people go like hey I think
yeah you know you go yeah great that's
great yeah and how do you pick these
roles what What attracted you to Bernard
on Citadel
um I liked the script I liked the script
I like the idea of it I like the role
because he was complicated yeah and he
became more and more complicated as we
worked on him I had more and more facets
to him I wanted to work with Richard I
was a big fan of him yeah Russia
brothers were involved uh and originally
we shot the original bit that we shot we
shot 40 minutes from my house in London
so that was pretty exciting that is
pretty cool and it's been shot in Spain
in all different places Morocco is zero
our favorite place you never went there
why why you weren't invited in those
scenes if I was if I'm if they're in
Morocco or there and whatever and I'm in
a room somewhere giving them information
yeah
you know wherever we were shooting right
yeah and the fact that the show was made
in so many different places and it's
showing a global stance of how the world
looks and seeing different spin-offs for
different countries I'm excited about
the fact they're doing it in India it's
what does it mean that this is a new way
of looking at a series and the
perspective of it and celebrating
different diversities I think it's
brilliant yeah I think it's brilliant
it's going to bring so many first of all
it employs so many people yeah that's a
really good thing any anytime that's a
great thing
um and employing people in the Arts is
really important and in the you know
behind the scenes that's like super yeah
uh important we're talking
thousands and thousands and thousands of
jobs
um and that's great I think also it's
going to introduce audiences all over
the world to to actors
from all over the world yeah and that's
really cool yeah that's great and you
mentioned you love the fact that Richard
was part of this project were you a fan
of Game of Thrones
yes I'd only watched a little bit of
Game of Thrones the red wedding scene
the red wedding scene no I didn't see
that I didn't I didn't I can't lie it's
okay
um uh I loved what I really loved was
The Bodyguard oh yes I thought he was
yeah amazing that's a very very hard
role
to to play I thought he was brilliant
and with him taking on Mason Kane do you
think he's the new the Spy that everyone
is going to look at I guess as a legend
because a lot of people are comparing to
James Bond to all of that yeah I mean
look at him just look at him just look
at him right he's so handsome it's like
that's too much he's a sex symbol too I
guess
congratulations
yes he is it's so wonderful meeting you